GARY?
>> Reporter: EIGHT
TUDIENCE.
SIX VOTED FOR DONALD TPAST.  PAL
E E INHEAS
ELECTION
ONE WAS TOO TOT THEY HAVE IN CO.
WHAT I WANT TO ASTOF HANDS.
ANYBTHOOKS
AFTER HALL?
THINK HS
Y HIE THING
YOD ABOUT HIM WHEN YOUMP
AT'S THE WAYE'S BEEN AA
BUSINESSMAN.
HE'S LIED ABOUT THE 2020
STUFFED BALLOT BOXES, ALL MADE
UP.HE OF COUR
IT HE TKS20.
, VOD W DO YOUTH
>> PARHE MEDIANARRE YSK
ECUF YOU THINK IIMFOR HIM TO TAN
>> COULDN'T THE MEDIA HAVE
>>
THN OUR MIND.
KE HE IS
UNDECLARED WHICH IS WHAT YOU D
INRE IF YOU WANT TO ENDENT
>> I'MTINGF
OU
I'M VERY MUCRE
IN TTHAT WCEAND D PREFARSCE HE
6ARN TH, VOTEFOP ICE.T HE'S C
THAT'S THINKS. F
>> DO YOU THYIL IT
FOR PEOPLE LYOIEVE?
>>LL I
>> EVEEPLOSING
IN THE COURTS ND OAGAIN.
H SN HIS
MIND.THIN?
>>'LABSTAIN. AD
64-YEAR-OLD, IF YOU DON'T MIND,
ONE MORE  RSHE IN THE PAST TWO
?RES
AND B,UT
I THINK THERE E W ION
NARRATIVE.
INVOLVING ALL OFEW? CURREAT
C S
WHEN YOUAYW WHAT
A LIE IS A
ALL THESE TS HAVSAID, ONE  SFF
I WAS THWAITH MY OWN
EYESNONE OF IT IS TRUE
PEOPLE THIE TRIE WIL
TO BE TRUEYOAGHAIN.
>> YES.
LEANING REPUBLICAN.
DY WANTSTHEIOUT  AT THIS
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HEAR ABOUT
2024.
THFUTURE ANDT COME A
TONIGHT.ABOUT
A REGISTEREDOT
TWICE.
YO
>> I THINK IT IS T MOVE ON
CTION.THE 2020
I K LY BELIEVES . DO,>> I THINK.
IT TO BE TRUE.>>ET M-YCOH TH OF
HE'S VTE ABOORESED FOR TRUMP T
ELSE HE WOULDN'T STILL
TALKING ABOUT IT.E .HE NEEDS TO2
E MEDILDFOCUS ON THE HUGE SEGMET
2020 ISSUE. KNOWH
T ITTHINK HE SHOALKING OF THE I.
>>OR TRU>>AY, I'M STOP LYINT ID
I'LL MOVE LD LIKM TO MOVWOULD  P
ABOUT IT.
IT IS HIOPINION.
THE TITH THAT
ION. TO HAVET ER A
JURY FOUNDE FOR
SE.
AN CONTINUING TO MOCAN THIS WOM
SEXUAL ABUSED. WASS A JURYPEEWON
TH OS
HODO YOUL THATTILL MAKING FUS
WHEN ASKED THE QUESTION?
>> IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE. UNCOMFOR
TO THINK ANYMO H ABOUT THAT?S M
SO I REALLY --ON FEEL LIKE
FETHIS WAS A JURY.
HAVE TO SAY R STE STATESAMERICA.
TH I AMAZINGTENOT A PERF BUTN
AMAZING SYSTEM, PARTICULARLY
COMP TO LOTS OF OTHER
COUNTRS.GREED ON THIS.
HERE HE IS AT THIS TN HALL
I'VE NEV MET BEFORE.ING FU HER.
HOW DOES THAKE YL AS
WOMAN?
N'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOU.
WOMEN CAN BE VIC OABMESTORL THE.
I DON'T ALL THESE SIIOLERE 20,0
S
>> ONE MORE QUESTION FOR YENCED
THAT HE DOESN'T THINK PENC
HE DOESN'T FEEL HE NEEDS TE TO H
ES?
>> I JUST WANT TO TELL MIKE 'M .
COHAED ANYONFENDED BTHAT?
>>E. A OF YOU READY TO SAY
TE FORALD